hey kids do you like hearthstone how
about the Elder Scrolls well the Elder
Scrolls legends might just be the game
for you I've spent a good amount of time
with the beta and while they move around
some of the names anyone familiar with
bar stone will instantly understand the
game's mechanics and layout online
versus arena mode microtransactions it's
all here however there are some
differences that make the game stand out
when you start up for the first time you
pick one of the ten races from the
series which race you will pick
influences the type of cards you will
collect and earn allowing you to more
easily gain cards for the deck and play
style you want to build you can of
course change or race at any time
legends features a full story mode which
functions as the game's tutorial in fact
you have to play it to certain points in
order to unlock access to the game's
other modes but it's worth going through
the whole thing to unlock cards and
starter decks the story even attempts to
bring in some of that elder scrolls
flavor by having moral choices these
choices don't change the story in any
way but rather have you choose between
two cards in game one of the big
differences you'll notice right away is
lanes creatures in one lane can't affect
the other adding an extra layer of
strategy in your card placements lanes
also have effects on them such as
protecting creatures for the first term
in there and play or randomly blowing a
card to the other Lane there is also the
ruins system five of your cards are
randomly placed inside ruins every loss
of five health breaks the ruin and you
get that card in your hand if the card
is labeled prophecy you get to play it
for free it's a nice way to give the
losing player potential boost so the
match doesn't become one sided for deck
building you can build your deck around
two of the different card types decks
have a minimum of 50 cards than a max of
70 you can also have three of the same
card in a deck instead of two like
hearthstone another interesting little
mechanic is that after lots of use some
cards will get upgrades allowing you to
choose between two different superior
versions it's an interesting idea that
your cards will get better the more you
play but I wonder how this will affect
the balance of the game
of course this is an Elder Scrolls game
and features plenty of fun little knobs
to the series such as the arena
announcer from oblivion the adoring fan
and yes that one the Elder Scrolls
Legends is a well made game and I had a
lot of fun with it but it's also a
familiar one I'll be curious to see how
much staying power and fan bases has
when the game is fully released later
this year on PC and iOS if you want to
try the game out for yourself before
that though there is a beta that you can
go sign up for and if you want to see
more coverage of this game stay tuned
gamespot
home early